we have our place clapping speaker
series today with Miss killer Velasco
people already make Spanish service
currently working at are they that's
terror group radio network leader in
Spain specializing in investigative and
data journalism she has exposed
political and economic now practicing
speak and uncover high-profile
international cases her reports have
focused on revealing unlawful and
unethical activities of the powerful
against the public interest you are is
the author of two books one about social
change in Spain and another one about
the riot of indignados the Occupy
movement voter which have been
translated into several languages
she had also published two essays in
Germany but the challenges of democracy
in Europe in the context of the economic
crisis and how new models of citizen
participation are emerging she's a
member of the strategy group the soul of
Europe the European Union initiative to
strengthen and Connecticut men connect
to be communities through different
frames of discussion she collaborates
with several digital media platforms
radio stations and TV channels in Spain
and Latin America
Pilar teaches investigative journalism
in Madrid
at conferences across europe and latin
america he is also the founder and board
member of the spanish association of
investigative journalists with the aim
of promoting cross-border investigative
journalism and reinforcing freedom of
expression today I will be speaking to
us about investigative journalism and
democracy and turbulent times good
morning everybody thank you so much for
coming also considering that today is
kind of a party day so I really
appreciated and his Monday which is a
lot so as Saskia presented to me
my name is Pilar Velasco a journalist
and investigative journalist I live in
Madrid I'm very sit there
I work in cadenas her radio is like NPR
radio or Spanish radio in Spain the
biggest is owned by presumably a media
group which is also their biggest media
company in Spain and I am seeing that
you're from kind of different countries
here and also I know some of you that
specialize in some fields that maybe I
just I'm not going to stop in the
presentation but we but we can talk
about it later so feel free to ask me
later about another issues big cases of
other countries cuz I just have selected
a few cases so so we have the chance to
to tour later and think about the role
of journalism is like a common space to
say that is so linked at with democracy
I mean journalism when his weak the
democracy of the country and the
institutions get weaker also and if we
agree I'm going to underline a
definition of journalism dialect Ron
Adolphe aux which is the founder of the
New York Times in 1860 in 1896 and he
says that to give the news in partially
with without fear or favor regardless of
Paris said or interesting ball bed and
does the role of journalism in general
so fat speak for themselves he used to
say son investigative journalism we have
to unveil the fats we
this pretty much the same but sometimes
requires a different strategy tools and
everything so that's my philosophers
powerful specialization was wronged with
some cases I started doing that in 2005
and and I would like to put some context
on these because in 2005 Spain was doing
really good
the economy was busting we were the
eighth economy of the world which is
pretty good so through those years until
the crisis in participate like in a
really hard way I could testify how her
the cases the corruption cases hits a
country and its institutions and make it
as I said before salsa wickedness so to
make her to start I have to also make a
definition of what corruption is him in
journalism him in general let me put an
example a book by the journalist Norman
Osler based on the files of Hitler's
personal physician and beer I think is
it has like a couple year this world
this book and build the use of drug use
using during the third rate of Hitler's
that's corruption the use of public
money for your own interests so with
this example the use of public money
link it to the abuse of political or
business power has secured in Spain as I
said in all the major institutions of
the state highlighting the need of
journalism in two ways why was so
important the use of journalism not just
in a local way but also in an
international way of it because all the
corruption networks even when they are
so local they hide themselves out of the
country it happened in Spain it happens
in France in Italy all over the Europe
and also if we switch to continent the
money from corruption cases from Latin
America are hiding in Spain as the money
from Spanish corruption cases are hiding
in Latino me
and the reason is easy they go away from
the local laws and local accountability
so I underlined son of the definition
here and I'm so when we talk about
political corruption
it goes to different categories it's
like they're you're I'm sure you have
heard that like it goes from black to
white it's the term that we use in
corruption from and there is so many
grace on it so corruption wars by this
man how it works also it goes
dismantling the control system of the
institutions expanding the post era of
Franco in the post Franco period it was
a such a model of success I'm sure you
have heard of it the successful model of
of a Spanish transition and it was
because we in Spain sort of built such a
really strong network of institutions
during the 80s
what happened 20 years later when this
all this money were coming through
credits and bank and busting and
construction business was that the
institution's start and the politicians
of course dismantling all these
political controls and institutional
controls so when we see as journalists
as observers as police makers when we
see that these institutions are taking
away doesn't those controls we have to
put the focus on is and how it works
also we are in Spain as I said in 2005
was so easy to go from the concrete
cases all over Spain and all over the
communities we have 17 communities
communities which are like states here
in the federal states here and so we
were reporting like case one case one
case one case one thousands thousands
until we saw that it was sort of a
pattern a pattern that effects all the
institutions as I said to make it funny
I'm going to put to make an example of
what's a pattern in journalism
I'm sure you know this movie a spotlight
2015 his Marty bottom the Edit executive
editor and chief of Washington Post and
in this movie he's trying to explain to
his journalist and why it was not enough
to report about 50 priests that well
comedian abuses in in the chart and he
said 15 OSA is not enough and the real
and the journalists were like 50 is not
enough in a car in a city like Boston
and that was the answer to define God as
a pattern you need to focus on the
institution about the individual priests
practice and policy
show me the church manipulated the
systems of these guys we have to face
charges show me they put the same
priests back into parishes time and time
again show me this was systemic that it
came from the top down we're going after
the system
I think that's the bigger story so
practice and policies and that's the big
story how the system works to allow to
allow that those corruption cases could
be alive because a patent allows two
things which are so important a pattern
corruption allows two to maintain this
corruption in the time and maintaining
in the institution which is like kind of
surprising how can you have a corruption
system into an institutions for so long
so that's when you have to go through
the system and that happened in Spain
for kind of a the Spanish citizenship
price in all those live liars
government monarchy banks political
parties institutions public companies
across borders which is pretty much a
lot and shocking so I'm going to show
you I mean to just talk a little bit
about some of those cases how could we
go from transition succeeds to these
kind of headlines that this one is like
from two years ago not even two years
ago span is never ending corruption
problem I have to say that this kind of
headlines from 2007 cans for after 10
years of journalistic war - so I I have
choose this case of everybody like it
about the monarchy in Spain because
everybody knows the monarchy in Spain
and why people got so angry about this
case the Spanish royal corruption
scandal was sort of a like a typical
corruption case in Spain and the
son-in-law of juan carlos formell king
of spain make a foundation nose
foundation and i underlined the six
million euro of public money into tax
havens because as i said all the money
always goes away and with her agua his
wife and the Infanta Cristina they were
sort of being benefice when they got
this benefit from public contracts
she was not condemned he has been
condemned like three months four months
ago in 2018 for more than four years of
prison he's actually imprisoned so the
citizen penis pain got so angry because
you know monarchy gets so much public
money and days I mean they have kind of
date represent a state of Spain and they
have like a big budget for those kind of
expenses so the people the citizens acts
why do you need extra money I mean why
do you need to steal through a
foundation so much extra money why do
you need to buy a castle of more than I
don't remember the millions of dollars
you have all of the all of their
business from the from the kingdom and
the patrimony and their whole houses so
this case was like sort of
representative of this kind of basic
packet of corruption the say the scandal
is kind of still on three months ago
maybe two this last summer now is facing
accusations of money laundering it makes
its hoping an interesting debate which
is nothing about investigative
journalism but I will like to underline
the king of Spain cannot be investigated
because he's protected by the
Constitution so we haven't noticed kind
of the very life how our Constitution
camp rotates a king from possible
penalties so he will not be investigated
but the German aristocrat claims the
former king pocket eighty million euro
from a contract with arabasadi there are
like nobody knows where but it happens
three months ago the case that it was a
big case was this one this case also has
all the meaning points of a corruption
case it or it it released in 2011 and
the condom goes this year a few years
later and the judge of this case was
really hard pressure by the prosecutors
which are selected for the government
and it was really hard to maintain this
case on trial through those years until
he got the the penalty depression
sentence I'm sure George do you also
remember this case I'm in this case
sorry austerity in Europe
do you remember how when Europeans North
countries called the South 1p Peaks
yeah they Portuguese Italy yeah Greece
thank you and where are we on Spain yeah
Hannah Spain it was the types of the
rescue in Europe the rescue of the
southern countries in Europe and this is
the de cobre that makes no doubt about
it because the government later refused
the rescue rescue to his fame Spain was
rescue in a different way than Greece or
Portugal Spain was save it through
through its banks the Eurogroup gives
all those millions to save the Spanish
banks because they were crossing and
when the when the rescue takes was in
the same time than the rescue was going
on in Europe they investing the
corruption investigators starts to grow
up in the national core because they the
politicians who run who used to run the
bank and now also a few years later we
can say that they were supported by as
the Guardian defines future of great
crow nation and political meddling there
is so many kind of wrongdoing cases
around the Spanish banks I'm just going
to underline a few of them they were
using credit cards black credit card for
their own expenses so now they are I
mean they are they will go to jail for
that
also they let me see ya in the bank ASAP
OH
during hits Monday do you I don't know
if you remember him
Rodrigo rato he was a former IMF
president and Minister of Economy and
the government of Costa Mariana a few
years ago you're pretty young to
remember that
and so how they how they did it they to
splint in any way they was they were
taking the money of the citizens like
now really in a couple months maybe less
and just to try to go to the market and
now there is being investigated and I
can pretty much assure that they will be
condemned for that so I don't want to
jump to this case it was a really
representative case about how the rescue
and politics and democracy is so linked
it with them with how the politicians
were running the bankers which is the
National Bank in his fame the government
after these cases had after Bank across
after being raised before Europe had to
nationalize the Spanish bank demeaning a
Spanish bank um
this case I see the huge case because we
will need like books and faces to to
talk about this case good take case is
the the case that has the caused a
career to Mariano Rajoy the former
president and when I was applying for
that for this fellowship for the world
fellow he was the president of Spain and
he had to resign like a couple ma a
couple Coppola in July maybe Natsume
sorry a girdle case is so representative
of this kind of cross-border cases it
affected of course the president a few
ministers well a few dozen of ministers
of Spain it caused the career and they
have to resign some ministries or
presidents for communities and it tooks
to journalists like
years - to maintain this case alive with
so many pressures from the government
I remember that the newspaper from my
company in one year in 2010 was holding
like exactly nine suits from the
government just for informing for this
case but even the police was being sued
by the government just for inform about
this case so try to imagine a country
with a heart crisis 20% of the
population unemployment all those
pressures and beginning for me and I
maintain like there
yeah the level of to inform so this case
this case was released thanks to the
rogatory Commission's I don't know if
does the properly were in English
Commission's when you ask to another
judge in another country to give it
another judge sorry no to the country to
give you information about the bank
accounts and they yeah them the bank
accounts abroad so after like three
years finally Switzerland answer to a
Spain and it was more than 30 million
euros hide them by the treasurer of the
Poli of the Conservative Party hiding in
Switzerland they were they were hiding
this money in Switzerland and in Latin
America they they use another way to
hide the money they have fake businesses
so you could you could find the treasure
the treasurer of the conservative
political party they were governing by
that time having business of Orange
landscape or how was another one which
was impossible I mean like really fake
because he was being the treasurer so he
could not be I think he got a kind of
good in Uruguay so they were having
business in Roubaix Argentina Mexico
Brazil and so on so it tooks to the
journalists a few time and to the court
to realize where the money of the
corruption was being hiding in Latin
America and I said that this is a long
case because after this case
so many police police maker has seen
some policies for it for instance
Switzerland changed the law to help
countries like Spain to make this change
of information quick at least and Latin
America also has now really strong
agreements to help those cases don't
last nine years some time which is I
mean I was young when this guy started I
was almost up it was I was like close
finis in my college time and so I have
just a case just for I hope don't bother
you so much with this case but for me is
an example of this good time kind of
upsets in a good way of how any local
case that we take a journalist and or
even like researchers and we realize
that it's always behind of really big
case when politicians are involved is
they the warrior contrasts in Spain and
Latin America is the stars in Madrid in
2005 when I start these cases it was
2005 2006 and but it has the biggest the
biggest company water company is public
companies still public and the Spanish
by public companies in Spain starts
doing business abroad I mean in Africa a
million Latin America because of their
of the relation of the both countries so
this transnational case starts in Madrid
like in the capital of Madrid not even
in the community and and finally now it
has impacts those in countries through
the contrast of border and services and
has revealed a contracting system under
judicial is finally under judicial
investigation it take us so long to
finally to get the court investigate
this case and we're talking about
millions of euros in bribes commissions
and illegal
financial or political parties not only
in Spain but also in Colombia and Panama
and also the investigation is being
opening in Brazil now what's important
about this is that it was not only
effects into the budget of a community
like Madrid but it was really impacting
the lives of the citizens in some so
many communities in Colombia for
instance some communities like Santa
Marta but I'm all day all the coast from
Caribbean coast and if you take those
year from 2005 to 2015
you could see like the people could not
even get water or healthy water and the
Spain was responsible of those contracts
because we were like putting this public
company abroad that's like a perfect
case of why corruption matters and why
it really effects at the end when I mean
when you have like this kind of system
the service is not being doing doing all
at the end of it so finally it was like
the Spanish soda bread that his Colombia
we have started as I said this case in
Madrid inna and finally Grimm we managed
to open this case in in in Colombia a
mega police operation in Spain that
effects all the water from Costa del
Caribe the police six I have just put
some Sun of those why why I put this
example like a real example of
cross-border journalism because it was a
case just working in the media and I was
I was working this thing with this issue
with just a couple a couple
editor-in-chief's and we had to do it by
ourselves because it was not an
investigative for Police investigative
open so how do we work it and we start
working with in all those countries
where we didn't have resources to travel
and even Colombia was sort of dangerous
place
by myself so I we realized that we could
be developed for ICIS colleagues and we
saw the the fellows from international
consortium of investigative journalists
said journalism based in Washington
they're pretty known now for Panama
papers but they they have a loan story
working in those cases and it was useful
also to share some databases sir access
of Records what I mean for access of
records when you don't have really
resources and you're working like trying
to make a local global global case you
cannot pay like all the register from
Panama in Dominican Republic so on so on
so try to make a network of fellows that
are already paying for those that those
are the bases and try to share them and
this kind of network the gooiest are
creating with those kind of local cases
in 2010 were so useful 5 years later
when we had all of the big cases that
I'd mentioned before lawyers different
lawyers from different countries who
were so useful too and we also create
some alliances with European media
colleagues front a media center for
instance or etc just to help us to
follow the banking entities financial
movement companies checking exact etc
etc and in Switzerland Luxembourg occurs
as I said it was in Latin America and
sweta the money and the fake business
and also in Spain and UK we call we have
like this
we saw Pam finally this kind of
Investigation which also loca had a good
result the former president of Madrid
went to jail the judicial case has
affected to so many countries that I
have been that have this kind of
judicial investigations open and I would
like to underline also it was the first
time that Colombians fame make a
judicial case like a mirror being the
the justice system is working together
in this case like we're with a new
mechanism
that helps also journalists to keep
going with this investigation and and I
thought this will the judicial case has
suffered similar pressures that all of
all of those kind of of investigative
cases the prosecutors as I mentioned
before is the fiscal health with chosen
by the government so try to avoid the
police operation finally in this local
case I would like to undermine what I
was mentioned before about the system
and the pattern it was a local case but
at the end was affecting ex ministers
ministers secretaries of states
prosecutors and use when the police
released this local case it was a net
were of a lot of people from the
government behind it and allowing to
this case being a life yeah oh yeah
sorry
I forgot I thank you sorry so the
investigation keeps going on um in all
those countries as I mention and we
finally open also commissions in
different Parliament's local ones and
the general one and the important thing
is I forgot to mention it there is not
an investigative case if he's kind of
success that has not an impact in the
population and also in the system I mean
when you have a wrong system you have to
transform it so finally the regular
contrasts have been suspended and last
week the company has been taken by the
public sustaining in Colombia until
those fats are a Creole accredited and
the recovery of the money found in tax
havens is being recovered the the money
from tax haven has been found in in a
lot of countries as I mention and just
also again this is
for pointers works are good in any kind
of global issue that you want to start
media freelancers local communities and
technology and databases and and all
kind of Records and the four point is so
important you need technology and unit
innovation you need to create databases
for any kind of issues as you record
that you do to start working on because
when you start those cases they always
looked pretty much local any of the
cases that you take but they gets bigger
believe me and I mean bigger can be like
even if you have 50 people involved that
gets bigger so please technology
database that's so important I even have
to do so many courses in 2014 to to keep
going with those kind of investigation
because I needed to to know how to use
those that the basis all around the
world local communities are so important
and and yes is a scheme that I am we are
using in my media and a lot of
colleagues are using in in every kind of
investigative issue that we work I also
want to underline the benefits of those
kind of networks do save resources to
make a global case you will network and
you set collaboration with your partners
and you amplify your your case I want
imagine what will happen if we stop
those kind of cases at the beginning of
the investigation if two years later we
said okay we have a local case here I
mean we have make a big breaking news in
our community so just stop the case I
mean it's good to keep going on it's
true there is not so you need sort of
patience if you're a journalist because
you have you're going to be like a long
time undercover and we like to we don't
like to be undercover as journalism so
but I mean it's a it's a good advice
that I received a few years ago and and
it was just like be patience the big
case will appears at the end so just
keep trying to work on this one
and as I mentioned before the
unprecedented judicial collaboration I'm
we're I'm really excited about it cuz I
never thought that we could make an
impact also in the way of prosecutors
and and judge works from different
countries and it allows also to get more
witnesses confessions driving by the
investigative research and when someone
make a confession
in Colombia there is a heat a backlash
in in Spain because someone is feeling a
cue set and that happens also with
Brazil witnesses with other witnesses in
Switzerland I mean they can to accuse
each other to try to save each other so
is the perfect moment of a masterful
investigation and the tension between
both judicial investigation cases
benefits both sides when one's was
harder the other one stood don't get
back so it's like the healthy
competition is always good in any field
so I put this case also because 2011-12
it was another example about I want to
keep going with the question about how
good was to learn how to work with
different countries and and have those
kind of collaboration already done
because because when when for Chinese
he's a whistleblower like like it was
know them like so many booster blowers
this one is it's nothing was import is
not in fact and it was important in
Spain because he was attainted in Spain
and the database was released in Spain
and the police working with these
database here the database had this
130,000 tax abiders all over the world
and we were working in those I see I was
working on these L'Amour newspaper in
France too and we were working on this
case too and only France and Spain's
have recovered 600 million users and
it's another example of case that
it was it has so many up and downs so
many times look like the case it was not
it was not going to success because the
judicial investigations that has helped
28 countries it was also an
investigation here in the United States
and the judicial investigations had to
be coordinated that's that was kind of
also pioneer in that in that moment they
had so many pressures so it was so
important the role of the of the media
here in so many countries working
together in in these kind of cases to
maintain them to maintain in our lives
and also I'm going to keep that one
because I don't want to see by self
judicial investigation has has Sue's and
I I'm putting this as an example also
the collaboration i journalist realize
how important at the networks broke when
you when your shoe and because when your
shoe is like okay you have your company
behind you but you don't know how long
it's going to take a case under trial
against you so when people know what
you're doing when you help those kind of
networks i mean there is an institution
i reporters without borders that help
you when do when you need helps or when
they understand that something some some
kind of pressure has to be has to be
released to everyone so Reporters
Without Borders was so important as so
many ones in Spain because we had this
kind of pressures that are happening
here now with tram what can I say like
even the Ministry of of treasure and I
release a case about it was in Mexico
semak's company now I'm not it was not
so big at least it was as semak's is a
big company a big huge company and the
Ministry of Spain condom 500 million
euros of penalty so I released that like
the ministries come down in five hundred
millions euro to a company with no
reason so the ministry from the Congress
accused to the owner of the company to
he said I know Ministry of the Treasury
and I know your depths so Don
go back to me can you imagine the
Ministry of the treasure I mean of
course you know so lot numbers but we
are media I mean we have the right to
have that even the right to have depth
but that's how the pressure and the
networks are so important also tuned to
go under that I underlined also some son
of the numbers so you can admire him I
mean you come Guerra an image of how
corruption hits a country and ninety
thousand millimeter per year according
to the Spanish national chamber of
markets and competition and murder of
the health of the of the amount of the
proud is extra cost I mean it's so easy
to make that kind of I mean they always
do it also in Spain they they put the
double price and they and you never know
where where is they half of of it and it
costs more than five hundred per year to
do it citizen and those has those are
data from Udo group re European data
also and seventy thousand people was
arrested only in one year politicians
and business people most of their
politician in all kind of levels and
their rest people went from three to
that I mean sure you can multiply that
and the cost of corruption I mean do you
all know that eliminates free business
competence also alters electoral and
democracy competence between political
parties because I mean there is no
competence if one political party gets
so much money than the other one there
is a political party financial political
party because of that to make an equal
competence and it makes quickens
confidence institutions and increase the
possibility of extra mission and
populism remember a case I mean there is
not a scientific study but I always
remember a case in France when film and
the candidates figure was like a strong
candidate pretty much close to him and
has to resign because because of
corruption case because her her wife was
being benefit of his church so in that
moment I was like I got those I'm Li
Peng was getting so strong and by that
time micron was not in there in in a map
so it was like we have all those strong
candidates resigning at the same time
that lived and the stream right and a
stream political parties get so strong
so I mean we have so many examples of
how those kind of abuse of power
hits political parties and benefits
extremism and and in a global context
it's the image of your country abroad I
mean of course I will I would love to
choose another issue to talk about the
Spain you're all invited and but I
thought it was an interesting case to
him he had to make the picture of how
how is so obvious that those kind of
cases that we'd kind of he so late
sometimes and we put like in the box of
corruption are so much linkit to to
democracy what happened in Spain was
that in it was so few years that the
cases were higher than the we said
economy in be so those big cases those
be democracy was being harder it was way
bigger than than the regular one so I
think we have time I mentioned at the
beginning that I work like in Thank You
kooky I'm insane at the beginning like
we can talk about any of your cases
friend your country so feel free to acts
more specific about cross-border yeah
he's living in his fame actually um his
the justice from Switzerland is looking
I mean his day Axford extradition
they already acts again this year 2018
and it was so close to make an exchange
between file Chinese and Catalunya
politicians it was close but finally the
Spanish justice says I mean he helps I
mean he was he's a collaborator of the
used is still now I mean even he has his
white and blacks but he's he
collaborates with Spanish used his
friend Eustace an Italian Juan actually
now and he's running some program about
silver currency and I mean his his pain
United States here in this room
the corruption what have been going on
for years one things that interest me is
I watched the Brazilian nightly news
from aa so loud three nights a week
every night with except during the World
Cup every night there is a major segment
you indictment and so on and you know
they show documents and then there are
words that come off the screen of the
main words in the document and they show
numbers and whatever and is just
relentless and that it's like a standard
formula and then at the end of this they
have they each there's two presenters
one man one woman who both alternate
meeting the responses of the lawyers of
the accused and these are totally false
charges this has been going on for years
the graphics have gotten better it's
affected it's one of the ways in which
the in every household of the
consciousness of corruption and the
culture has been affected in Spain has
there been something like this where
there's just this relentless always in
the news thing or these like bursts I
forgot to mention how also corruption
hits the queue tool of a country I mean
it permeates everything and that also
happened in Spain during some years like
the country was changing so quick and
not in a good way because it was like
yeah it was a culture of you get benefit
for something for a system so why to
complain and it's so hard to I have read
so many researches about the cost of
corruption in politics and I mean you
cannot find a good conclusion and an
ending conclusion but it's true that at
the end and they have to resign at least
I mean all those cases that I that I
have talked they have to resign in Spain
it was so many years and nobody cares
about it but also it was this indignados
movement in Spain in 2011 actually and
we used to have an astronomy party the
same in Spain with them
some conservatives socialism and
conservatives and it break down in 2014
two new political parties appear and
they appear claiming against corruption
merely against inequality for podemos
and against corruption for two Delano's
which is like us stream left and center
right I mean and they were claiming
against corruption and they have like
more than 60% of the young population
boats I mean the jungle people are
voting for new political parties which
claim so hard against corruption so I've
seen at the end it cares I mean yeah
when you see your country being heating
for economy we used to have the fifty
five percent of young people under 25
and employment same rates than Greece
and Italy and citizens were we're
watching the old cases on TV so it was
like I mean in a country like a Spain
which is not so big for a five million
citizens and you can have a dialogue
between government and citizens and the
protester wars were so high I mean I put
the monarchy case because it was like a
heat like I mean even the monarchy
you've been thinking extra money but you
don't need it
so I mean she is patience also with with
those cases it looks like nobody cares
he's like this fine rain and suddenly
boom something happens so
who are sane us Barton as the treasurer
of Purcell using the newspaper all the
time yes I mean I think is good I mean I
think it's good I think it's good yeah I
mean if I will have to choose choose
over inform because at the end you're
informing about corruption which is not
I mean it's not in the entire mint and
you I mean it's useful information for
people we were so many years who about
like nobody cares about those cases I
was so many years like though I asked
him for favors like please can you
release this breaking news on Sunday
afternoon at least yeah five years later
I was doing breaking news all the time
but I mean I think it's good to pay yeah
you know member-countries corruption it
seems that every Treasury secretary
Minister national finances has anything
has something to do with international
banking kingdoms in Spain what's
associated I don't know if it was with
Goldman Sachs would be my brothers or
one of those he was working there was
never investigated he was sitting there
with Rocco for many many years and he
was in direct contact with international
banking yes I mean the other hand
through
directives and rules prohibit any
hindrance on the government of character
between countries so they are free to do
whatever they want right they put their
they put their hand in government and
then they relax the rules yeah but this
is a personal opinion and of course I'm
affected but for the issue that I work I
also agree that the European Union will
be stronger or at least in the past
because it's true that also has been a
change and in those kind of cases when
they have release is harder to reproduce
the same cases again and I didn't talk
about the benefits but so many laws have
changed and it's true that when you have
all of those cases when you can put when
I mean when you cut put Minister ex
former ministers on jail is back it's
because system works I mean that's for
sure
but yeah I mean I will expect the same
because they in the European Union they
respect on me the countries so even if
some ministers of Commissioners are
being investigative in the wrong
countries for some kind of penalties
they can keep going in the European
Union under changes and there isn't
there is not a clear protocol for that
like I mean if you've been investigative
or you if you have those business if I
mean I think there is something to the
something else to do but you try excuse
me oh yeah yeah I mention rotten well
right away go he was condemned to jail
exactly this much yeah he was a
president and the American sued him
because he had some crazy secret yeah he
has actually like six investigations
under him so I think we can rest calmly
is his what
man yeah yeah sorry
so you mentioned that in a lot of your
cases there was government pressure to
kind of keep it by it
how do dermal is find allies that are
not corrupt to keep the investigation
the pressures are like dat end of
journalism got good Sammy we were kind
of good with those pressures if your
media is strong enough to hold them but
we really help a lot between each other
I'm saying those kind of collaboration
and networks are really getting a
stronger so quick I'm I'm seeing some of
those examples giving those weeks here
like the New York Times runs a story
about a Russian spy and they need
someone from Spain helping them because
it affected to Spain also I mean we
really we really those kind of networks
that I mention like consortium and other
media they're working so good even in
United States for example for the White
House now in the Trump administration
which is being harder for us Europeans
to get in we will work in in consortiums
we go like we we work each other like
five big media for example I don't
remember which one like Lamoni PI's and
we feel rather like the big ones and we
ask for the same interviews and I mean
those kind of collaboration works like
in investigative teams and also in the
regular news and Panama papers as an
example it's a good example of that and
I mean yeah globalization also has
changed in a listen in a good way so we
help each others when there is pressure
we ask for we ask for help
from their perspective they wait to
change the system because for my
because my opinion bring forth the law
is kind of their the only way and
reinforce the controls of the
administration I mean you have to avoid
it it's true that what do you win I mean
what do you end with having seven
I don't remember seven hundred thousand
politicians being investigated for those
in some subs on year you have to prevent
it because when they are in jail is
because something has been broken before
and something system affecting so many
people so I think the Prevention's are
the only way and I mean mr. Casey is an
expert on that but countries has to make
a stronger agreements to share
information to share databases I mean we
have those crime crime organizations
working so easy all over the world and
so link it with politics also in Mexico
in Russia I mean all around Europe and
you can see them working like like in
the 80s like it takes weeks to share
information sometimes with no years
there is cases in Spain open in 2011
that they're waiting for answers still
now it's just later because they Samsung
Commission and it was something wrong
they get back the years so in I think
they have it's prevention laws and
that's the only way and control and
control yeah empower and mechanisms to
clear mechanisms to so the politicians
arts has to have like the clear
mechanics like if you
doing that you have to resign so I mean
in a Spain is working at least since two
years three years not three two years
one year ago the mechanism has been
reinforced in some institutions and it
feels we see five years later it sees
that it's kind of preventing a little
bit transparency we journalists worked
so hard to have an transparency logo in
his pain and it has like three four
years it's pretty new and the deputies
in the Congress of Spain didn't have to
show up their businesses until one year
ago which that was hiding so many
businesses undercover so transparency
transparency and response here
[Music]
we journals yeah yeah we work as a
sources we will go a lot to trans
international transparency - there is so
many institutions the Tahrir there is so
many institutions for instance to help
you to open contracts public contracts
those kind of contrasts that are closed
in a country and you have to open them
to get information to see who's behind
those businesses because well it is I
mean political corruption is always
about some money we hide money so for
the political party or for themselves so
yeah we work a lot with those who
organize Asian yeah Angela it was
they change the culture
but no one was interested in the
journalists who took these cases which
was so
investigations that were not years with
the banks the football teams the
politicians around Parliament as
did they kind of impact screen in terms
of Kennedy very important about how hard
it was to get this investigations
yes I mean yes also with Italian Spain
the agreements has changed in the last
five years for good
I remember a case that is a different
one I didn't I haven't worked on that
one so I just know they're from but we I
work in a case about how Calabria mafia
Dan Greta was penetrating his pain and
the police was working on that it was
the first time they saw Calabria my
Mafia's done Greta mafia trying to go
through the institutions in Spain and
and it was possible because of the
Italian police and the Spanish police
with the special agreements to work
together going through and they could
they could share information that
otherwise you cannot share because you
know Polly a Spanish police yes can work
in Spain as Italian police so special
agreements were so good to avoid and
react penetrating to Spain maybe now
there is some money of tan Greta but is
it lose that there is not yeah groups at
least a day one
no my life I just know I'm in Spain is a
safe country
I got like pissed off some furious cuz I
was like okay there is so much pressure
and it makes me go slower I mean we do
have pressures you go as low and that
makes me right but it's true that we
have Ben Grimm I want to stop I think
doing what I do so life's make you work
better I mean that's why you keep
working and I kind of hog we're about
the protection that we will need to have
in those time looks like like them by
Roman is changing for journalists I can
see like I mean even in Europe this this
year we have this the first they kill a
journalist in Malta the mother of one of
my colleagues from my age and he's like
wow in Europe they're giving today was
in the news like Bulgarian journalist
that was investigating European founds
was killed too the police doesn't know
if if he's related but I can I mean
because so that the big cases are going
to I'm I'm sure of it
are going to be so link it through so
many countries and okay you can be safe
in Spain but who who tell you that
you're safe in Ukrainian so I think we
will need to create like safe safest
networks to work with to war between us
sorry and to work with communities
because at the end those kind of cases I
mean even if is global the impact is so
local it impacting in a small
communities and we have to protect also
the sources that times to us and and of
course they yeah both sides so I think
we yeah we will need for communities and
journalists then we will have to think
about it better in the near future
[Applause]
[Music]